jalisa is with us in Philadelphia hi
jalisa how are you I'm good how are you
better than I deserve what's up
well I'm 23 years old I have about
$31,000 in debt and I dropped out of
college two years ago and I was
wondering if you think it's a good idea
to go back what were you studying I was
studying a logical engineering but if I
go back I'll be studying cybersecurity
okay and what a long will it take you to
complete your degree um after I
transferred my credits
maybe two or three years depending on
how serious I am about it how many
classes I take that's right are you
going to be working while you're doing
this yes okay what do you what are you
doing now what do you make I'm a
software engineer so I make seventy six
thousand dollars years and you retain
that job and go study cyber security at
night and so forth yeah definitely
thank you pay cash as you go okay well
you're making focus on paying off my
debt first before I go back to college I
don't care you know you're probably
going to be able to do both but the
first thing I want you to do is just lay
out a really strong budget where you can
cashflow college and all that's going to
do is slow down how fast you get out of
that I hope I hope it doesn't mean you
just do nothing on the debt but if you
didn't what kind of all student loan
debt eighteen thousand of student loans
seven thousand is my car and five
thousands of credit cards okay all right
well the student loans will go on
deferral as soon as you get back in
school I have something I assume they
will and and so that's helpful and if
you can you know way along those other
two and get rid of them that'd be great
to have that out of your life make it
easier to cash flow school right
absolutely your company pick up any of
your tuition
um five thousand that's nice yeah
and where will you study oh just a local
school Wilmington University
okay and so it's not super expensive
right very good which is why it
transfers as I was at a more expensive
University the University of Delaware
and so that's why I decided transfer to
Wilmington and it's also more flexible
for people who are working okay well I
mean listen at 23:00 you're obviously
bright you're articulate talking to you
you're carrying yourself well just
having a conversation here in front of
all these people on the radio electrical
engineering software engineers cyber
security these are all you know strong
strong spaces that you've been thinking
about and playing in and it leads you it
sounds like this path I can hear the
path pretty clearly it's ledger this
cybersecurity idea and you found
different pieces you enjoyed about
different things and combine them and
that's what popped up and the good news
is it's a very exciting space that you
could enter a career because the money
is astronomical and and the sky's the
limit because I mean I don't see this
slowing down the need for this anytime
soon it's probably gonna get worse and
you know my little 700 person company we
fight it over here like crazy you know
you keep our stuff secure right and so
yeah you got a great field there that
you're going into and so all of that to
say the time that you spend and the
money you spend to complete that degree
field you'll get a great return on
investment on that over the next decade
okay because it's going to set you up to
make some good money and be very very
very employable it's just as you know
it's a hot space and so you know you're
gonna do great there definitely so what
let me ask you is have you already
priced out school what's it going to
cost um maybe if I don't take any money
from my company why would you not
technically from your company well just
because it has some limitations to it as
as far as um how long I have to work
there and everything like that so well
you have to pay it back if you leave
right right right
it okay and if you leave pay it back or
make make the people that you that that
steal you away pay they pay you a
signing bonus to cover it right right
take that right that's what I was
thinking I was I was definitely leaning
for taking it yeah I got the $5,000
what's school cost only 10 10k a year
okay and 5k that 5k out of your 76
you're single single lady and your game
on
I mean you've strapped on the helmet
you're ready to win the Super Bowl
lean in here right and you know that no
pun intended with Philadelphia right but
so but happens to be a caller from
Philadelphia dave says that to one of
the chances but anyway the so you know
you're but your game on and so you take
this 76 thousand yeah you put five in
the company puts five in and you still
beat on this debt you still should be
dead for even the time you get out of
school absolutely right you said what
two years three years yeah two to three
depend on the credit transfer that's
right Yeah right
okay cool hey you're on fire I want to
hear how you're doing let me know later
how you're succeeding okay absolutely I
will thank you so much please get after
it I love it very well done see you
people talking about I talked about this
all the time she's 23 okay now we get
all this stuff in the media the
Millennial this Millennials that
Millennials get a bad rap that they all
live in their mother's basement and all
this kind of stuff I got to tell you I
meet more julissa's than I do
participation trophy living in their
mother's basement but now I don't run in
circles where I would run into
participation trophy get the guy I don't
run into him I run into the julissa's
because I'm a high performer I demand
excellence of the people in my life and
the people on my team and so I just
don't attract you know I matter of fact
I'm I'm pretty repulsive to entitled
spoiled brats they don't like Dave
Dave's not politically correct he
doesn't give them a safe space you know
and all that crap so now but but the I
tell you the Millennials are trying to
their julissa's that kid is game home
man at 23 she's a rock
star that's awesome stuff right there do
you hear that call that's amazing